[Music]
hello everyone
in this lecture we are going to discuss
another problem
uh from 2d elasticity
where the polar coordinate system will
be utilized
and this is the problem of the pure
bending of a curved bar
now as you can see in this
diagram we have this
thick curved bar
and it is subjected to this kind of
pure bending moments which are
externally applied this m naught is the
externally applied bending moment
the inner radius here is a this is b
these are parts
these are arcs of concentric circles and
we are supposed to find out the
the stress distribution here now
if you think about it for a moment this
problem
uh although it is it is
it does not involve full circles it is
still very much
an access symmetric problem it is an
axosymmetric problem because
no matter which cut section you may take
along the length of this curved bar
you will see that there is no difference
in the stress distribution there we
still don't know what the stress
distribution it will be
but you take any cut section the
situation will be the same
because at that cut section the only uh
the only uh
resistance that will show up will be a
counter
a a bending moment to counteract this
externally applied
bending moment okay so
the most important uh question to ask
and and to get a grip off before we can
proceed to the solution of this problem
again in jupiter notebook
using symbolic python is uh
what are the boundary conditions present
here okay
so this is our entire geometrical domain
and we ask what are the boundary
conditions
so just as we had done in the case of
our previous problem on the pressure
vessel
we can note immediately that at r equal
to
a and at r equal to b we can
write down the values of the sigma r
r okay and they are very much
zero for this problem unlike the
pressure vessel where we did have
an internal pressure acting at radius a
and an external pressure acting at
radius b here
we do not have any such pressure so the
values of
sigma r are both at r equal to a and at
r equal to b
that is going to be 0 so we write that
down first of all
so sigma r r equal to 0
at r equal to a
sigma r r is equal to 0
at r equal to b
done next you note that
uh this is a situation where we do not
have
any force along the axis of this bar
what i mean to say is that there is no
axial force here
there is no axial force here all right
so how can we represent that we can
so you please note that suppose you had
a let me just use this little little
rough space here
suppose we had this kind of a very
familiar
beam situation okay now
usually we take this kind this kind of a
longitudinal axis
to be our x so that the stresses present
here
are like sigma x6
it is a very rough drawing of course so
that the entire axial force
for this beam would be expressed as an
integration of the sigma
xx over this length and through this
thickness
in this case what is the normal stress
acting on this vertical face or this or
this
edge or this edge what is the
normal stress that normal stress is
nothing but sigma theta theta
so the the axial force
being 0 that has to be expressed in
terms of the integration
over sigma theta theta for the present
case
so sigma theta theta here uh that has to
be
integrated over
r considering these kinds of
elemental strips of thickness dr
where we also understand that into the
plane of the screen
we have a width
equal to 1 and this integration
has to be carried out from
r equal to a to r equal to b
and that result is going to be equal to
zero
for the final boundary condition uh
i will have to write down the bending
moment and this is
uh this is the most important one
because through this
the externally applied load will come
into the
picture for that what do i need to do so
you please note again uh for
our for this kind of a beam the
bending moment would be written in terms
of so suppose if we have
this cam this kind of a y axis here the
bending moment
would be written as y times sigma x x
d y integration from minus h to h where
twice h is the height of this beam
correspondingly if we consider this edge
we again have to write the by
the bending moments in terms of this
sigma theta theta again
but this time multiplied with the moment
arm
r so what we write is
r sigma theta theta
d r times one so you understand that
this part
sigma theta theta times d r times one
that is the
elemental force acting over a little
elemental thickness
of this edge the r is the moment
arm which will uh which will result in
this
bending moment and we have to carry out
this integration
from a to b now this is a very very
important point what i am going to
discuss now let me
just consider this edge separately here
okay let me just consider this h
separately
and i slightly uh zoom into it
what i'm doing here is basically this
i'm considering a little elemental
thickness
okay with this thickness this is my
dr
this is my dr over this
i have the presence of my sigma theta
theta
which is normal
which is normal to that plane
and the moment is
is calculated using this r variable
so that is in this fashion
so if i have to take the proper sense of
this moment
i have to remember the convention of the
vector cross product which actually
generates these kinds
of moments so that comes out from the
consideration of
r cross f uh here the f
is due to the sigma theta theta so the
sigma theta theta
times d r times one where the one is the
unit width into the plane of the screen
that is my elemental
force that is in the direction of theta
and the moment arm is in the direction
of r so
overall the sense of the bending moment
will be
in this fashion will be
clockwise however you note
so as written this entire entity
that has the sense clockwise
but the externally applied movement is
given in an anti-clockwise fashion
so all that you have to do to capture
this information
is just to write this as minus of
m naught this is the most important
piece of
information that we write for this
boundary condition
there is another condition which we can
write here
which is that the shear stress along
this
edge the shear force is zero
but but you know
that when we considered
an access symmetric problem the airy
stress function
is going to be independent of theta and
we have already seen in the previous
video that when we have such an air
stress function
the sigma r theta identically turns out
to be zero
so without any further discussion uh on
this writing app let us go towards
the actual implementation of this
solution using the edit stress function
approach in the jupiter notebook all
right
so i have fired up a new file here in uh
jupiter notebook
and as before the first thing that i am
going to do
is to import everything from my polar
utilities
package
so from polar utilities import star so
the first few steps that i am going to
carry out here will be
exactly the same as uh what i did in
my previous file when i was trying to
solve
uh where i when i went want to solve the
pressure vessel problem the thick wall
pressure vessel problem
and uh so so likewise uh
what i'll do is i'll set up an air
stress function
which will be theta independent
it will only have a dependence on r
all right and as before uh
i can find out the polar by harmonic of
this
of this phi
and you see because i have set it up to
be
independent of theta there are uh
they're only the terms involving the
r here and now if i have to solve the by
harmonic equation
uh so
all that i have to do just like the
previous file
uh i'll have to solve an equation
and that equation will be
the polar by harmonic of pi
equals 0 so everything to the left of
this comma
is the left hand side of my equation and
on the right hand side
i have my zero so basically what i'm
trying to do here
is set up through this equation to this
eq
and this capital eq command built in
um that is built into symbolic python
uh the polar by harmonic equation okay
and in this step what i'm going to do is
solve this
equation so
so as before as in the previous video
i am obtaining this solution but again
uh
i would like to write down my solution
in terms of
capital a b c and d so again like before
i will just
quickly write rewrite this thing
phi will be rewritten as a times
log of r plus b times
r square log of
r the c
times r square
plus t and uh
i'll display this nicely but for that i
have to
first input this
from this ipython
let me just do that quickly
this is exactly like before
all right this is what i wanted now
uh with this in hand i can actually
go forward and try to implement
the or at least set up the boundary
condition equations okay so
for the first boundary condition let me
just take a quick look back at my
writing app
so the first condition is sigma rr is
equal to 0
at r equal to a
so the first lhs okay for the
corresponding to the first boundary
condition
that will be just the substitution of
the sigma rr with
r as a but you note that uh
i have not yet actually actually
set up my stress variables so i need to
do that first
i'll go to the boundary conditions just
after that so
again like the previous file i invoke
the sigma rr function call
that is already defined within the polar
utilities file
[Music]
similarly for sigma theta theta
i use it like this and for sigma rt
i have my function called as sigma
underscore rt
and i display all of this
in a nice fashion
this is my sigma dt and this i actually
write as sigma theta theta
and finally i have my sigma rt
so this is sigma r theta let's display
that
all right as i had uh said just a while
ago
the for for phi independent of theta
it will turn out that the sigma r theta
is actually 0 which had already seen in
the previous video
r now
again in the previous video we had
considered
the cases where the circular domain
would be devoid of any hole first
and then the case where it would
actually have a hole
including that r equal to zero point the
origin
now uh if we look at our diagram
this is certainly the case where
if you can just imagine for a moment
that these arcs are parts of circles
so this is actually the center of that
circle and
we do actually have a hole here
okay so this is our whole now
when we had discussed in our previous
video that for the considerations of
cases
involving such holes
there can be very many different cases
and
we had gone on to take the particular
case of a not equal to 0
and b equal to zero but
now for our particular for this current
problem
of the of the pure bending of a curved
bar we don't have to make any such
a priory assumptions what we can do is
we can keep the abc unknown as they are
let me go back to the jupiter notebook
file these a
b c i will keep them unknown as they are
and instead i will just set up my
boundary conditions
and let the maps take care of these
values it will turn out
that i can actually obtain proper values
for corresponding to those boundary
conditions so first job at hand now
is to set up the boundary conditions so
for the first boundary condition sigma r
equal to 0
at r equal to a the left hand side will
be just the sigma rr expression but
where
the r is substituted by a
next for the rhs i just have
zero so the first equation corresponding
to the first boundary condition
will be lhs1 comma rhs1
that's it and i can display this
next for my second boundary condition i
have similarly
the sigma rr where r will be substituted
by b
and the rhs will be simply 0
this will be my second equation
let me look at the third boundary
condition
this third boundary condition is written
in terms of the sigma theta theta
and that is actually an integration from
a to b
so lhs is equal to sim dot integrate
sigma t uh
r going from a to b
and r h is so this is going to be l it
is 3 and
rho 3 is equal to 0.
so my third equation
be set like this
and i can just display the third
equation also
and finally for my fourth equation
so for my fourth equation let me take a
quick look here
what i need to implement is this r times
sigma theta theta
integration from a to b that is equal to
minus m naught
now if i come back to this jupiter
notebook you will note that
nowhere till now i have defined my m
naught
okay so it's high time that we did that
so
let's say this m0 is defined like this
so for the lhs again i have to implement
an integration
this time r times sigma t
and the domain of integration is the
same as before
are going from a to b the rhs this time
will not be 0 rather it will be minus m
naught
so equation 4 equation number 4
correspond to the fourth boundary
condition
will be set up in this fashion
and again i can display this fourth
equation as well
so let me implement this very important
input cell let's see
uh right so i had forgotten to
define these inner and outer radii a and
b
so what i can do is saying in this cell
i can press my
escape key and press
the letter a so that an input cell will
be
incorporated just above it it is not
necessary for me to go to
uh a new input cell but this will be a
reminder of what we
demonstrated in our in our preliminary
lectures
so we have inputted an input cell so a
comma b
so this will be symbols
a comma b and i know that they need to
be positive
that's it and this time it should work
all right so i have four equations and
these four equations
are being demonstrate are being
displayed here
now uh you please note
that and they may look a little bit
complicated involving the log and
everything
uh but if you just look at the unknown
quantities
okay this a b c
they are so these four equations uh
they are very much like linear
simultaneous equations
uh involving this a b and c
okay so we have uh
apparently we have ended up with uh four
equations
or three unknowns but not a problem
because symbolic python we know
can handle uh this kinds of situations
as was demonstrated in an earlier in an
earlier video also corresponding to
the case of to that example problem of
the simply supported beam under uniform
loading where we had
actually supplied more equations than
the number of unknown coefficients of
the air stress
function so not a problem okay
so let's actually go ahead and try to
solve this equation this system of
equations
so for that same dot then solve because
these are linear equations that just
mentioned
the equations are equation 1 equation 2
equation 3 equation 4 and the things
that i am going to solve for
are a b c and r d
well i don't need d so a b and c
all right now this will be stored
in this or packaged into this solution
variable
let's just see if this thing works
so it has worked fine apparently because
no error is being
displayed so what we can do is
we can extract the the solutions
uh into some
into some variables like this
so a solution is equal to
solution index 0 b solution
is equal to solution index 1
and c solution is equal to
solution index
alright so you can display these things
in a nice fashion
quite repetitive in nature but the end
result is nice
as you can see these are quite long
expressions
okay
and you can also see that
there are some terms where you have
these kinds of dangerous looking
expressions
okay but what symbolic python has
basically done is
it has tried to shorten the the length
of these expressions
by uh by by doing some simplifications
or well depending on your viewpoint
whether it's a simplification or
complication it has tried to contract
these terms
using the properties of logarithms okay
but you can very well
expand these things and and work out
more simple looking expressions but uh
but the
but the bottom line here is that uh the
fact of the matter is that we have ended
up
with solutions uh for a b and c and all
that we need to do
is go back to the expressions of sigma
rr sigma
and sigma theta theta to ah and
substitute these
these solutions and we will
have our answer in our hand let's try to
do that
so sigma r our solution is equal to
sigma
r dot subs
a comma a solution
b comma b solution
c comma the solution
and similarly for uh
sigma theta theta
and we know that sigma r theta is
identically zero
so
we can again display this
in a nice fashion like this
[Music]
[Music]
this will be theta theta
let's see what this gives us
oh ah i had forgotten to write one
command here
so you see uh without the latex
rendering
it gives us not at all a pretty input
pretty output okay so we must uh
provide this kind of uh
let me retype that same dot later
sigma rr and
m dot latex
let's try this once again um
so i need to write this as sigma or
solution
otherwise it is just expressing the
original
unsolved expressions
so see these are quite huge okay
these are quite huge expressions
just look at that
okay so let's see what happens
if we try to simplify
these expressions all that you have to
do
is just ask same by two
use this simplify command
let's see if this gives us anything
better
so this is somewhat better looking
now you can see that
if you were doing this by hand then for
terms like this
what you would actually do is to expand
this out
maybe take the minus a square b square
as a coefficient of this log term
similarly here you take
the a square as a coefficient of this
log term
and proceeding similarly with other such
expansions you can get a
more familiar looking expression for
this sigma rr solution
and the sigma theta theta solution okay
but again the more important thing to
note is that
this kind of tedious algebra has really
been
been offloaded from your brain into this
computer algebra system of symbolic
python
okay and the good thing about it is i
again emphasize that if you require
perhaps numerical solutions to these uh
you can go ahead
and make the appropriate substitutions
plot it out and do
various kinds of post processing
analysis
with this all right so with this i will
end this lecture but uh with the
understanding
that this problem is not really over
because we have only stopped here at we
are only stopping here currently
with the solution of the of the stress
pills
but it is very much possible to go on to
obtaining the strain fields by
considering ah
linear elastic isotropic behavior and
then we can go on to find out
the displacement fields also so later on
we'll come back to these
to this file to this problem and try to
find out
those variables the strain fields and
the
and very importantly the displacement
field all right
thank you very much